peinture
[Musique]
paquette
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent
là elle en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
à la veille du des compliments france
des députés céiste conseil
constitutionnel sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
parmi leurs craintes la violation de la
vie privée et l'atteinte à la liberté
d'aller et venir pour les malades placés
en quarantaine
le projet de loi validé hier prolonger
l'état d'urgence jusqu'au 10 juillet
après 55 jours de confinement la france
a enregistré 70 morts ces dernières 24
heures le ministre de l'éducation veut
que chaque enfant retourne au moins une
fois à l'école avant fin mai
en europe la grèce prolonge le
confinement dans les camps de migrants
jusqu'au 21 mai prochain l'allemagne
elle s'inquiète du laus
question qui est passé à 1,1 en italie
700 me en france sont en difficulté
alimentaire à cause de la crise et de la
fermeture des cantines scolaires le
royaume uni lui présente ce dimanche un
plan de déconfinement a minima
nouveaux foyers de contamination aux
états unis avec encore plus d'autres
son décès ces dernières 24 heures
quatorze proche de donald trump sont
testés positifs au coc u19 dont l'un des
valets personnel du président de 73 ans
le chef de la maison blanche qui veut
relancer rapidement l'économie et qui
suivit de vives critiques notamment de
la part de son prédécesseur barack obama
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche dernier jour
de confinement pour les français après
55 jours de restrictions imposées par le
gouvernement à la veille du desserrement
la france recense deux nouveaux foyers
de contamination
l'un en dordogne au cours d'une
cérémonie d'obsèques l'autre dans la
vienne après une réunion pour la rentrée
scolaire
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire a été décidé hier voter donc
jusqu'au 10 juillet sénateurs et députés
ont trouvé un compromis sur la
pénalisation des décideurs notamment et
sur le fichier qui doit recenser les
malades et finalement le groupe l'est
républicain lui a voté ce texte au
parlement
vous voyez les précisions de raphaël
scheelen berger députés les républicains
du haut rhin la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence a été a été actée d'ailleurs
on a fini par la route et après après
accord avec le sénat mais sur le texte
initial le gouvernement a voulu
organiser son irresponsabilité en
quelque sorte pour nous c'était
particulièrement inacceptable le
gouvernement aussi le créer un fichier
de traçage des français atteint ou non
par le coronavirus et ce fichier à une
telle ampleur est initialement n'avait
avait si peu de garanties que nous y
sommes opposés je suis bien plus
d'agacer par l'empêchement de
fonctionnement du parlement pendant
cette période de crise parce que on se
rend compte que pendant presque deux
mois
le parlement n'a pas siégé il n'y a pas
eu d'expression politique ya pas eu d
expression démocratique
moi je suis bien plus embêté par cela
que par le fait que nous parlementaires
devions quand on retourne à l'assemblée
à partir de lundi très progressivement
comme tous les français respecter un
certain nombre de mesures
soixante trois députés de l'opposition
ont saisi le conseil constitutionnel
des élus issus du groupe socialiste
communiste la france insoumise et celui
du groupe les libertés et territoires un
parmi les craintes notamment la
violation de la vie privée et l'atteinte
à la liberté d'aller et venir notamment
pour les malades placés en quarantaine
le projet de loi inclut l'obligation
également de dae
rires le fameux fichier qui recense les
malades au delà de trois mois et pour en
parler nous sommes avec fabien roussel
députés du parti communiste du nord
bonsoir fabien roussel merci dans quoi
nous sur rt france
pourquoi avoir saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
d'abord parce que avec plusieurs de mes
collègues de différents groupes de
gauche nous pensons que ce texte de loi
contrevient à des principes de notre
constitution notamment sur les libertés
pas seulement les libertés individuelles
liées à la possibilité de nous déplacer
avec cette possibilité donc de passer en
quarantaine et personnes nous pensons
personnellement je pense que c'est bien
de pouvoir placer en quarantaine des
personnes qui sont infectées de pouvoir
leur proposer d'être mis dans des hôtels
quand c'est quand c'est possible
ce qui nous gêne c'est que la manière
dont ces rédigé dans le texte de loi
ce n'est pas du tout précise et ce n'est
pas assez clair les précisions seront
apportées plus tard par décret et nous
ne les connaissons pas et 6 à 7 des
sondés sur la base du volontariat cette
mise en quarantaine et c'est sur la base
du volontariat mais c'est un placement
qui peut être fait par donc les équipes
mobiles qui seront mobilisés mais ce qui
n'est pas précisé c'est comment ça se
passera pour la famille pour comment ça
se passera pour les mineurs nous avons
demandé de nombreuses garanties sur ces
questions là sans les avoir
et puis il ya aussi cette question du
fichier qui nous préoccupe je dirais
encore plus parce que autant là qu'ils
ont de la constitution d'un fichier
national pour suivre la chaîne de
contamination est importante et nous la
soutenons ce principe là ça peut aider
effectivement à lutter contre la
pandémie et la circulation du virus
mais ce sont là aussi les modalités de
ce fichier qui nous inquiète parce que
tout le monde pourra en faire partie et
beaucoup d'informations seront situeront
dans ce fichier
c'est à dire la nature du contact que
nous aurons eu avec la personne affectée
lieu la tuerie du contact les
circonstances de ce contact
enfin c'est une précieuse de
renseignements sur chacun de nos
concitoyens au prétexte d'avoir été plus
ou moins en contact avec une personne
infectée
alors ce jeu suit cette fiche par
personne devra être détruite dans trois
mois vous y croyez vous pensez que c'est
dangereux tout de même écoutez ce n'est
pas clair c'est un principe qui a été
mis dans le texte mais sans garantie
aucune
nous avons nous demandé à ce que ce soit
bien écrire noir sur blanc la
suppression de ce fichier nous avons
aussi préféré nous avons demandé
l'anonymisation des personnes c'est à
dire que l'anonymat de chaque personne
contact soit préservé c'est possible en
mettant des codes chiffrés pour pour
chaque personne parce qu' énormément de
monde va manipuler ce fichier des
personnels de santé mais pas seulement
ceux de la sécurité sociale c'est ce des
descentes sociaux des communes
ça c'est des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui auront un accès à ce
fichier national
comment faire alors selon vous fabien
roussel puisque est-ce qu'il faut
identifier et recenser les personnes
malades pour remonter les cas contraire
tout à nous aurions bien aimé non avoir
un peu plus de temps pour travailler sur
les règles plus strictes qu'il aurait
fallu mettre en place pour avoir un tel
fichier qui effectivement donc le leti
peut nous aider à bien connaître la
manière dont circule le virus et pouvoir
stopper la circulation de ce virus
donc nous ne sommes pas contre la
constitution de deux
un tel fichier mais c'est la manière
dont il est de mise en oeuvre
c'est le fait qu'il ne soit pas qu'il ne
préserve pas l'anonymat des personnes
et puis le fait qu'il ya énormément de
monde qui va y avoir accès et que
beaucoup de renseignements y figurant
sur chaque personne chaque citoyen
français peut faire partie de ce fichier
est donc nous aurions aimé nous y mettre
beaucoup plus de garanties nous avons
fait des propositions en ce sens pendant
le débat qui ont tous toutes été
rejetées et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous faisons un recours car
cela contrevient des principes de notre
constitution
elle avoue parler du problème de
l'anonymat il ya également le problème
du secret médical puisque les personnes
malades vont être recensés par le
médecin c'est lui qui doit inscrire dans
ce fameux fichier le nombre du malade ça
pose ça vous ce problème de secret
médical au sinon bah oui parce que ça a
été un point qui a fait l'objet d'un
débat puisque le secret médical
aujourd'hui il est préservé par les
médecins et là demain comme ce sera un
fichier spécifique qu'ovide bien sûr
tous ceux qui ont accès à ce fichier
sauront que les personnes dedans sont
potentiellement infectées par le
coronavirus vous imaginez les
implications que cela peut avoir ses
fichiers circulent je pense à la
personne qui voudrait contracter un prêt
auprès de sa banque
et alors si le banquier par avion par un
autre accès à la connaissance et au fait
que la personne est potentiellement
infectées par le virus il n'aura jamais
accès à son prêt bancaire c'est un
exemple que je donne mais c'est ce sont
des choses qui peuvent se vérifier puis
enfin quand même nous avons surtout dit
qu'un tel fichier ne peut venir que en
plus après avoir avoir mis en oeuvre
tous les moyens pour lutter contre
l'épidémie c'est à dire des masques pour
tous et en accès libre gratuit et la
massification des tests c'est surtout ça
qui est important
on ne voudrait pas que ce fichier ces
brigades mobiles pour aller chercher les
personnes contacts soit un prétexte pour
parce qu'il ya une pénurie de masques
parce qu'il n'y a pas de tests
accessible pour tous
c'est pour ça que c'est d'abord la
priorité pour nous c'est d'avoir des
masques en nombre et accessible pour
tous gratuitement pour chacun d'entre
eux
citoyens et ensuite que l'on puisse
faire des tests par tout compris dans
les entreprises quand les camps des
entreprises le propose que ça puisse
être créée or aujourd'hui c'est interdit
oui c'était interdit je vous le confirme
merci beaucoup fabien roussel je
rappelle que vous êtes député du parti
communiste du nord merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions sur les francs soit une
crise sanitaire qui a révélé on le voit
les difficultés de l'exécutif
elle a géré entre ordres et
contre-ordres cette période à montrer
les contradictions et les dissensions
entre l'elysée et matignon des français
qui retiendront surtout le mensonge sur
l'inefficacité des masques au début de
la crise ce sera d'ailleurs l'objet de
notre débat politique à 21h30 ce soir
rediffusion du débat voyez les
explications de l'udc a tué le 16 mars
au palais de l'elysée le ton est
solennel
la rhétorique martial nous sommes en
guerre
toute l'action du gouvernement et du
parlement doit être désormais tournés
vers le combat contre l'épidémie
le pays est en guerre les français sont
appelés à rester chez eux
pourtant la veille du discours
présidentiel
le gouvernement décide du maintien du
premier tour des élections municipales
le chef de l'état affirme que les
différentes familles politiques ont été
consultés sur le sujet la décision est
soutenu par le chef du gouvernement
notre décision a été fondée sur des
motifs scientifiques et elle est
parfaitement assumé sur ces motifs
scientifiques et c'est peut-être là le
premier couac dans la gestion de cette
crise par l'exécutif le maintien des
élections alors que l'épidémie commence
à sévir en france le sujet fait débat
l'opposition monte au créneau et dénonce
une décision unilatérale
je répète que jamais le rassemblement
national n'a été consulté par le
gouvernement sur le report du premier
tour des municipales
ce mensonge répété cent fois est
vraiment suspect non edouard philippe
vous ne nous avait rien demandé
concernant le premier tour des
municipales
ne fuyez pas vos responsabilités mais le
vrai caillou dans la chaussure du
gouvernement durant cette crise
c'est sans doute la question des masques
à l'heure où de nombreux pays à travers
le
de distribuer gratuitement des masques
de protection alors population la france
connaît une situation de pénurie colère
chez ceux qui sont en première ligne
notamment parmi les soignants et les
forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui les soignants que moi je
représente le seul problème que nous
avons c'est qu'ils sont toujours dans la
même situation qu'au départ sans rien
sans masque sans protection sans test il
ya un décalage entre les discours du
président de la république et les actes
sur le terrain
pour le moment les mesures pour nous
protéger ne sont toujours pas là et
protéger la population ce que nous
sommes en contact de différentes
personnes au cours de la journée donc
nous sommes aussi des vecteurs
potentiels donc c'est très compliqué de
travailler dans des conditions pareilles
car la france a besoin de policiers mais
deux policiers qui sont valides et qui
sont capables de faire leur travail au
cours des derniers mois les
préconisations du gouvernement sur le
port du masque ont été pour le moins
contradictoire
d'abord jugé inutile le port du masque
est ensuite recommandé et sera
finalement obligatoire dès demain dans
les transports en commun sous peine
d'amendé aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
indication acheter des masques pour la
population française les masses n'ont
aucun intérêt pour le grand public le
port du masque en population générale
dans la rue ça ne sert à rien je refuse
de recommander le port du masque pour
tous et jamais le gouvernement ne l'a
fait notre objectif est que chaque
français puisse avoir accès à un masque
soit par la distribution commerciale qui
peut exister aujourd'hui et ils y sont
très attentifs soit par les
collectivités locales qui sont engagés
soit par l'état les transports sont un
des cas où le port du masque pourra être
obligatoire à compter du 11 mai de quoi
s'y perdre
comme au sujet de la réouverture des
écoles annoncées par le chef de l'état
pour ce mardi
elle suscite de nombreuses inquiétudes
en france chez certains parents d'abord
qui redoute que leurs enfants ne
revienne infectés chez les mères ensuite
qui craignent que leur responsabilité
soit engagée en cas de nouvelles
contaminations et chez les enseignants
enfin qui parlent de mesures sanitaires
inapplicable dans les classes ce
brassage non voulues lorsque les gens se
déplacent à plus de 100 km il aura lieu
ont fait au sein des villes d'où au sein
de leurs écoles qui vont être de vrais
laboratoire
deux virus quoi concrètement nous moi ce
que je retiens aussi c'est qu'on mette
des cobayes concrètement on va voir
comment ça se passe alors on remet les
profs dans les écoles remet les
personnels on regarde ce que ça donne
sur les enfants les parent aurait pu on
avisera après mais c'est complètement
irresponsable pour les français ce lundi
11 mai marquera le retour d'une certaine
liberté sacrifiés au nom de la lutte
contre le virus
pour l'exécutif en revanche une période
difficile pourrait commencer celle des
contes et des explications sur une
gestion de crise très critiqué
l'exécutif qui risque de perdre sa
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
la semaine prochaine
des marcheurs aurait l'intention de
créer un nouveau groupe de députés parmi
eux le candidat à la mairie de paris
cédric villani ou bien un matthieu
orphelin ancien militant de la
république en marche un groupe qui
pourrait compter une cinquantaine de
députés et qui ferait donc perdre la
majorité absolue au parti présidentiel
un mouvement qui veut selon lui
recentrer le débat sur l'urgence
écologique la modernisation de la
démocratie ou bien la réduction des
inégalités sociales et territoriales
un groupe de façade c'est l'analyse
d'alexis poulain journaliste et
cofondateur du site le monde moderne où
une manoeuvre pour scinder faussement un
groupe pléthorique de députés playmobil
godillots comme on les appelle et pour
organiser une fausse opposition une
opposition de façade et capter tout
l'espace médiatique et le débat il
s'agit à la fois pour certains d'un
enjeu de survie politique de visibilité
pour d'autres de recyclage de 10 rebonds
et bien vu que cette étiquette du
nouveau monde
elle est complètement foireuse excusez
moi du terme j'en change où je fais
semblant de changer et qu'est ce qu'il
ya de plus facile pour changer et bien
on repeint en vert avec l'écologie parce
que tout le monde est d'accord c'est des
messages simples écologique aux
constructions à mettre davantage des
citoyens au coeur du projet c'était
rappelez-vous le projet des mre de
macron c'était un mensonge et bien là on
remet en scène cette fausse organisation
de l'opposition pour continuer à jouer
avec les français après deux mois de
confinement la vie va peu à peu
reprendre dès demain donc avec le début
des mesures de déconfinement beaucoup
d'annoncés ont été faites ces derniers
jours qu'elles vont en être les
principaux changements
voyez les précisions en
le groupe d'infections qui s'est
récemment déclarée dans les
établissements de loisirs a fait prendre
conscience que même pendant la phase de
stabilisation des situations similaires
peuvent se reproduire à tout moment
n'importe où dans un espace clos et
encombrées sera pas terminée tant que
nous ne serons pas arrivé au bout tout
en maintenant une vigilance accrue
jusqu'à la fin où jamais baisser la
garde en matière de prévention des
épidémies
[Musique]
monde
oh
des écoles qui vont aussi rouvrir leurs
portes demain et dans une interview
accordée au journal du dimanche le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel bancaire affirme que 86 % des
établissements ou bien ouvrir la semaine
prochaine il devrait accueillir un
million cinq cent mille élèves
voilà le ministre qui souhaite que
chaque enfant a eu au moins une fois à
l'école d'ici à la fin du mois de mai
voyez ce qu'en pense nicolas glières il
est professeur de français à paris
également administrateur du mouvement
les styles et rouge
les enfants sont des vecteurs
asymptomatiques ils vont contaminer tout
le monde
eux ne sont pas en danger la plupart du
temps ce qui rassure
malheureusement j'allais dire les
parents en gros concerts quand les
enfants ne sont pas touchés on s'en
moque
les adultes peuvent bien mourir c'est
pas très grave ben nous trouve ça grave
on n'a pas envie de mourir ou de tomber
malade
on n'a pas envie de contaminer nos
proches on n'a pas envie non plus que
les familles des élèves sont malades ou
meurent parfois c'est complètement
irresponsable en fait ce qui se passe on
voit qu'on est encore traités comme des
cobayes concrètement on a entendu tout à
l'heure jean michel blanquer a expliqué
que faire des tests pour les enseignants
c'était du gâchis
donc voilà toute la considération qu'il
a pour nous méprise il n'a aucune estime
pour nous nous tester c'est gâcher les
tests c'est incroyable c'est juste la
preuve d'un mépris total à l'égard des
personnels d'éducation
tous autant qu'ils sont deux mois de
confinement où le temps est comme
suspendu
je vous propose de voir ces images
inédites de paris la nuit images rares
tournées par florian bray thèse regarder
[Musique]
m
et
le
[Musique]
et
au royaume uni le plan des confinement
est présenté en ce moment même à la
chambre des communes par boris johnson
boris johnson qui souhaitent un
allègement mais très limitée des mesures
de restriction prolongement du
confinement jusqu'au 1er juin c'est ce
qu'elle a déjà annoncé le premier
ministre dans le pays le télétravail
sera maintenu le ministre de
l'environnement s'est dit plutôt
préoccupés puisque le pays n'est pas
tiré d'affaires at il dit avec plus de
31 mille morts le royaume uni est
aujourd'hui le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde derrière les
états-unis l'allemagne fait partie des
pays européens qui ont commencé à
desserrer les règles sanitaires depuis
la semaine dernière des mesures qui ont
été contestés hier par des milliers de
personnes dans le pays mais aussi voulez
vous allez le voir en belgique et aussi
en suisse grégoire doucet les allemands
redoutent une nouvelle mise à
l'isolément
alors que le déconfinement a débuté de
manière progressive depuis le 20 avril
dernier quelques localités ont décidé de
freiner la procédure
des mesures de confinement ont déjà été
rétablie par endroits une situation qui
n'est pas du goût de certains allemands
qui ont décidé d'exprimer leur
ras-le-bol comme ici à stuttgart où
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
réunies il évoque une atteinte aux
droits fondamentaux
le but de la manifestation de notre
manifestation générale
et de rappeler que les mesures prises
dans le cadre du corps ou des virus ont
fortement restreint les droits
fondamentaux et que c'est ce que la
majorité ici et les organisateurs
souhaitent que les droits fondamentaux
soient rétablies donc bien sûr ils sont
seulement restreint mais nous voulons
que ces restrictions soient levées
c'est en principe le plan des mesures de
restrictions dont une partie de la
population ne veut plus entendre parler
je crois que je suis avec les autres qui
font des revendications ils voulons
retrouver nos vies et nous voulons que
l'action gouvernementale nous ramène
dans des zones normale avec des
décisions clairement justifié qui ne
sont pas basés sur des spéculations des
simulations et sur la façon dont nous
allons avancer dans les semaines et mois
à venir et cela doit commencer avec la
fin de ce confinement
les protestations ne respectent pas
toujours la distanciation physique
donnant lieu à certaines scènes agitée
la police a par exemple procédé à
certaines interpellations à berlin pour
l'heure une règle prédomine 1re
confinement si plus de 50 cas pour
100000 habitants sont détectés en une
semaine
outre-rhin les modalités d'isolement
n'ont toutefois jamais été aussi strict
qu'en france nouveaux foyers de
contamination aux états unis avec encore
plus de 1500 décès ces dernières 24
heures 14 proche de donald trump ont été
testés positifs au coville 19 dont l'un
des valets personnel du président de 73
ans et c'est aux états unis que le
coronavirus fait le plus de victimes
78 7 78 780 14 morts au total mais aussi
le plus grand nombre de cas avec plus de
1 million 300 mille malades selon les
experts le bilan pourrait passer la
barre des 100000 d'ici à l'été
donald trump très critiqué notamment
pour ne pas avoir réalisé l'ampleur de
la pandémie au liban un couvre-feu à
nouveau à instaurer entre 19 heures et 5
heures du matin il s'agit de combattre
la hausse des contaminations ducobu 19
une crise sanitaire qui s'ajoute à la
crise économique qui ravage le
territoire le pays est surendetté le
gouvernement demande l'aide du fonds
monétaire international les explications
de lucas tueur crise économique et
coronavirus le liban est à genoux est
difficile de trouver une porte de sortie
quand le pays croule sous une dette de
92 milliards de dollars soit 170 % du
pib environ 5000 usines et des milliers
de magasins ont fermé depuis le début de
la pandémie
un libanais sur deux est au chômage les
demandeurs d'emploi ne perçoivent aucune
aide de l'état
un tel effondrement est sans précédent
cette génération est la précédente n'ont
jamais connu ça nos salaires ont été
réduits au quart de ce qu'ils étaient à
cause du manque de dollars et personne
ne surveille l'inflation le monde entier
assiste à une transition économique à
cause du courant navires us tout le
monde souffre mais au liban nous allons
souffrir davantage à cause de ce qui se
passait avant le coronavirus pour se
protéger des caprices d'une économie
fragile
les libanais sont habitués à jongler
entre deux devises la livre libanaise et
le dollar américain depuis 23 ans le
cours de la livre est indexé sur le
billet vert avec un taux fixe 1507 livre
pour un dollar
problème avec la crise la livre perd de
sa valeur
la pénurie de dollars s'intensifie il
faut désormais plus de 4000 livres pour
acheter un dollar nous importons en
dollars et nous commerçons en dollars
concrètement si je veux apporter un
produit je dois payer en dollars
aujourd'hui je suis confronté à deux
problèmes
gd dollars sur mon compte mais quand je
demande à la banque de faire un virement
en dollar à 1 2 mais revendeurs
la banque refuse et me demande du cash
nous avons tous renoncé à l'idée de
demander des crédits car nous n'avons
plus confiance en notre système bancaire
le gouvernement ne veut pas porter seul
la responsabilité de cette crise en deux
semaines pas moins d'une cinquantaine
d'agents de change ont été arrêtés dans
le pays est accusé de manipuler le taux
de conversion
jeudi dernier c'était au tour du
président du syndicat des bureaux de
change
les autorités l'accusent de fortes
spéculations contre la livre libanaise
dans le même temps le gouvernement
libanais a présenté un plan de relance
au fonds monétaire international
le projet ne fait pas l'unanimité
je ne considère pas cela comme un plan
c'est un discours avec des remarques
économique et financière adressée au fmi
par le gouvernement au lieu de soumettre
un vrai plan économique solide hasard
mais lier wanna be your man ma
aujourd'hui le liban se retrouvent
contraints de demander un prêt au fmi
pour assurer les suites des activités
économiques est pour pouvoir assurer les
besoins essentiels du pays
il y a beaucoup de choses à dire sur ce
plan notamment au sujet de
l'augmentation des impôts
notre économie est en récession le plan
stipule que les impôts augmenteront
cela ne fera qu'ajouter encore plus de
pressions sur l'économie la crise
économique a été l'un des déclencheurs
du mouvement social qui secoue le liban
depuis l'automne dernier
du nord au sud du pays en passant par la
capitale des milliers de libanais
accusent la classe politique de
corruption et d'incompétence
un nouveau gouvernement a été formé en
janvier mais pas de quoi calmer la
colère de la population
le liban sortira progressivement du
confinement à partir du 24 mai une date
qui pourrait signer le retour en masse
des manifestants dans la rue
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
pour tenter de limiter l'impact de cette
crise économique liée aux colis de 19 un
plan de soutien à hauteur de 110
milliards d'euros a été déployée
restaurons et ceux ci étaient
d'événementiel disent indépendants vont
mettre la clé sous la porte
quelles que soient les aides qui leur
seront accordés la casse derrière si
l'économie ne repart pas si la confiance
ne repart pas elle va être terrible vous
savez aujourd'hui on perd près d'un
million d'euros par jour et on peut
considérer